- Derrière ce mur, le long
de l'avenue du Parc, un oasis
de verdure et de quiétude,
presque inconnu des Montréalais.
C'est là que les Hospitalières
se sont installées, en 1659.
Et une quarantaine d'entre elles
y vivent encore.
CHARLOTTE MOREAU DE LA FUENTE,
agente à l'éducation,
Musée des Hospitalières
- On a la chance qu'elles soient
toujours là, elles habitent
toujours sur le site. Donc, les
impliquer et conserver vraiment
leur esprit, leur patrimoine,
toute l'âme des hospitalières,
je pense que c'est ça
qui va être important.
- C'est le mandat que la Ville
confie à Entremise, un contrat
de 360 000 $, pour imaginer
l'avenir du site.
En tout, près de 40 000 pieds
carrés de bâtiments à utiliser,
comme l'immense salle
de la communauté. Mais il y a
d'autres locaux à valoriser.
PHILÉMON GRAVEL, dir. général
et cofondateur, Entremise
- Ici, on voit par exemple
l'ancien magasin, toute
la calligraphie à la main
des soeurs, les petits tiroirs
avec chacun leur tissu fleuri
à l'intérieur.
- Il y a aussi un atelier
de couture, avec vue sur
le Mont Royal, ou encore
une salle de coiffure.
Entremise ne va pas monter
un grand projet de A à Z.
Elle compte sur la matière grise
des Montréalais.
- Tout le monde pourra proposer
une idée et tester cette
idée-là. Avec tous ces tests
d'idées-là, on va voir qu'est-ce
qui fonctionne, qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne pas, et c'est là
que l'occupation transitoire
et le côté expérimental va
nourrir la vocation pérenne.
Quand on visite le lieu, on se
rend compte à quel point le lieu
est en bon état. Et donc, c'est
ce cadeau-là qu'il va falloir
reprendre en main et trouver
une communauté qui va poursuivre
cette vocation et cet entretien.
Ce que ça nous prend ici,
c'est des gardiens des lieux,
comme l'étaient les soeurs.
(chant religieux)
- Il n'y aura plus de service
religieux dans la chapelle,
mais peut-être des conférences,
des rencontres, de la musique.
Et des espaces pour étudier
en silence au balcon.
MAEVA VILAIN, conseillère
d'arrond., Le Plateau-Mont-Royal
- Enfin, on va pouvoir ouvrir
ce lieu patrimonial magnifique,
ce havre de paix aux
Montréalais. On sait que
c'est quelque chose qui est
très, très attendu.
- Mais est-ce que les jardins,
par exemple, pourraient être
accessibles en tout temps?
- Un fragile équilibre entre
l'ouverture et la conservation
de la quiétude des lieux.
- Derrière ces fenêtres,
il y a aussi une quarantaine
de chambres, qui pourraient
servir à des artistes
en résidence ou à des personnes
marginalisées. Le grand atelier
attend aussi d'ouvrir
ses portes à des artisans.
Ce nouveau projet s'éloigne
des plans annoncés par
l'ancienne administration...
- C'est une extraordinaire
journée.
- ...après l'achat des bâtiments
pour 15 millions de dollars
fin 2016.
- La Ville s'est donné
comme défi de rassembler
des organismes capables
d'arrimer ce vivre-ensemble
aux enjeux actuels et futurs.
- Mais l'administration Plante
veut croire qu'il est préférable
d'arriver seulement avec
un cadre général et de laisser
la population se l'approprier.
L'appel à projets doit être
lancé dans les toutes prochaines
semaines avec l'espoir que dès
cet été, il y ait des activités
culturelles, citoyennes
et sociales ici dans ces lieux.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.